Transcription: Michele Gianella
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
“On ne choisit pas ses parents,
On ne choisit pas sa famille
On ne choisit pas non plus
les trottoirs de Manille
De Paris, ou d'Alger,
pour apprendre à marcher
Être né quelque part,
Pour celui qui est né,
C'est toujours un hasard"
J’espère que vous avez
cette mélodie dans la tête :
c'est une chanson
de Maxime Le Forestier, en 1988.
Et cette chanson m'a toujours inspiré -
et je dirai même,
d'une certaine manière, intrigué.
Avons-nous choisi de naître ?
Est-ce que vous avez choisi, par exemple,
votre lieu de naissance ?
Est-ce que vous avez choisi
votre date de naissance ?
Avons-nous communément choisi
nos conditions de naissance ?
La réponse est un grand "non" !
Mais cette expérience de pensée
est un point de départ fondamental
pour ma réflexion.
En philosophie politique,
on fait souvent la distinction
entre les choix, d'une part,
et puis les circonstances, d'autre part.
Les choix, c'est ce qui relève
de notre volonté,
de notre responsabilité ;
les circonstances, quant à elles,
dépendent de facteurs externes
à notre volonté et à notre responsabilité.
Alors, si naître n'est pas un choix,
pourrions-nous dire
que naître est une circonstance ?
Cette fois-ci, pas de faux suspense :
la réponse est oui !
C'est d'ailleurs, peut-être,
la première des circonstances :
la mère de toutes les circonstances.
Et peut-être, aussi, la cause première
qui nous unit toutes et tous
aujourd'hui ici.
Alors, si je n'ai pas choisi de naître,
je n'ai pas non plus choisi
la société dans laquelle je nais.
Je n'ai pas choisi pour moi-même
de naître en démocratie -
ou pour d'autres, de naître en dictature.
Je n'ai pas choisi de naître pauvre,
comme je n'ai pas choisi
de naître dans l'opulence.
Alors, vous l'aurez compris,
si nous n'avons pas choisi de naître,
si nous n'avons pas choisi la société
dans laquelle nous naissons,
je considère pour ma part
que la société nous doit quelque chose.
Et ce quelque chose,
c'est une part qui nous revient.
Un revenu suffisant pour assurer
nos conditions d'existence
au delà, indépendamment
du travail et des aides sociales.
Et ce revenu d'existence,
je le nomme moi-même, comme d'autres,
"revenu d'existence".
Un revenu d'existence, c'est avant tout
pour assurer notre existence,
recevoir individuellement,
sans contrepartie, sans conditions,
une somme qui nous permette de vivre.
Dans mon dernier livre,
je raconte l'histoire
de Mehdi, Sarah et Valentine,
puis je les suis, de 0 à 18 ans,
depuis leur naissance -
mais aussi leurs parents.
La question que je pose, c'est :
quelle aurait été la vie de leurs parents,
s'ils avaient touché
un tel revenu d'existence
mensuellement ?
Et puis, quels auraient été leur choix
si à un moment, plus jeunes,
on leur avait dit et promis,
constitutionnellement,
qu'ils allaient toucher
une dotation en capital,
une forme d'héritage pour tous,
sans que, d'ailleurs,
il n'y ait personne qui meure
pour que je puisse le toucher ?
Et vous,
imaginez que vous puissiez toucher
une somme régulière, mensuelle :
est-ce que vous feriez
des choix différents,
indépendamment de votre travail ?
Est-ce que vous vous engageriez
dans la cité, dans le bénévolat,
dans une forme de contemplation,
ou peut-être, feriez-vous des choix
professionnels différents ?
Et puis, si plus jeunes,
on vous avait dit,
indépendamment de vos
conditions de naissance,
que vous auriez touché une certaine somme
pour pouvoir assumer
un projet de vie différent,
quelque chose qui aurait pu être,
davantage, porteur d'espoir
ou qui aujourd'hui vous aurez permis
de vous insérer différemment
dans la société.
Moi-même, je me suis posé cette question.
Parfois, avec une certaine frustration.
Mais il est à peu près sûr
que j'aurais aimé voyager, davantage ;
et puis, il est à peu près sûr
que j'aurais aimé passer
une année à l'étranger,
dans une université américaine
ou en Grande-Bretagne,
là où la philosophie politique et morale
connaît de beaux discours.
Je n'ai pas une grande frustration,
aujourd'hui,
mais je pense quand même
qu'une partie de ma vie aurait changé,
et que j'aurais fait des choix différents.
Mais tel n'a pas été le cas.
Je suis issu d'un milieu populaire,
d'un milieu populaire certes
lettré et militant.
Ma maman est porteuse de handicap
depuis sa naissance ;
je suis moi-même orphelin de père
depuis l'âge de mes 17 ans.
Mais je ne veux pas faire pleurer
dans les chaumières.
En revanche, dans mon quartier populaire,
j'ai rapidement été confronté
aux injustices socio-économiques,
aux inégalités;
mais aussi,
à l'extraordinaire force du collectif.
Et puis, très jeune,
je me suis rendu compte de quelque chose :
une valeur, un horizon moral,
qui finalement ne m'a
jamais quitté depuis.
Cette valeur, ce principe,
c'est l'égalité :
et je dirais même, davantage,
le principe d'égalité
et la soif d'égalité.
Et tous les choix
que j'ai fait par la suite,
que ce soit universitaire,
dans mes combats politiques,
ont toujours été en faveur de l'égalité.
Avec un objectif très clair :
allier la théorie, la pensée abstraite,
et la pratique au quotidien.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'exactement
le revenu d'existence ?
Je le dis tout à l'heure :
individuel, sans contrepartie,
sans conditions, universel,
donné à toutes et tous.
En première partie,
on pourrait dire qu'il lutte
contre l'extrême pauvreté, la précarité.
Mais pas uniquement !
Il redonne aux uns et aux autres
le choix, une certaine liberté
de s'engager plus pour les autres,
plus pour la société,
de choisir un travail différent,
de ne pas toujours subir ;
et de regagner une choix.
Le revenu d'existence,
ça pourrait être une innovation radicale
en matière de justice sociale,
peut-être l'occasion
de se reposer collectivement
l'idée d'un pacte social,
pour résoudre en partie -
mais c'est déjà bien -
la crise sociale,
démocratique et écologique
que nous subissons aujourd'hui.
Une alternative parmi d'autres,
mais une alternative quand même.
Et puis, le revenu d'existence,
il entend répondre
à un impératif particulier :
l'impératif de dignité.
Et qu'est-ce que la dignité ?
La dignité, ce sont
les moyens d'existence,
la reconnaissance sociale ;
la dignité, c'est assurer les conditions
essentielles de l'existence.
Et c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître un peu banal,
mais il n'empêche que certains
ont besoin de boire, de manger,
de se vêtir, d'avoir un toit,
ou d'accéder à une hygiène élémentaire.
Le revenu d'existence
ça n'est pas non plus,
comme certains le pensent,
un revenu pour solde de tout compte,
qui anéantirait l'ensemble
des aides sociales existantes ;
au contraire, je crois personnellement
à la force du service public
en complément du revenu d'existence.
Ce service public qui apporte
l'éducation gratuite, par exemple,
à Mehdi, Sarah et Valentine
et à d'autres enfants.
Ce service public qui donne l'accès
à la santé, aux soins élémentaires,
sans avoir besoin de se ruiner.
Ce revenu d'existence
peut radicalement changer la donne.
Mais on peut se poser
une question essentielle :
doit-il vraiment être donné
à tout le monde ?
Est-ce qu'un enfant qui naît
dans un milieu aisé
devrait pouvoir aussi le toucher,
et la réponse est encore une fois oui.
Pour une raison simple :
même nés dans un milieu aisé,
vous n'avez pas choisi votre naissance.
Et puis, j'y vois un certain avantage :
si vous touchez ce revenu d'existence,
quel qu'il soit,
plus tard,
si vous restez dans un milieu aisé,
vous pourriez davantage
contribuer au pot commun
pour que chacun puisse toucher
ce revenu d'existence.
Et puis, je vois aussi un avantage :
enfin, une fois pour toutes,
de lutter contre la stigmatisation.
Puisqu'il est automatique,
puisque tout le monde le touche,
il n'y a pas de raison
de jalouser l'autre,
ou de penser que l'un serait un profiteur
ou que l'autre serait
un fainéant dans cette société.
Il ne résout pas tous les problèmes,
ce revenu d'existence,
mais il permet de résoudre
un certain nombre
que notre société connaît aujourd'hui.
Alors, quelle est la différence,
peut-être, que l'on peut avoir
avec d'autres types
de revenus d'existence ?
Certains auteurs,
que j'ai largement lus depuis longtemps,
pensent le revenu d'existence seul,
d'ailleurs peut-être
pas toujours depuis la naissance ;
d'autres pensent qu'il faut plutôt
une dotation initiale en capital,
qui permettent de donner ce starter
nécessaire à des jeunes
pour commencer convenablement dans la vie.
C'est ce que Thomas Piketty, par exemple,
appelle "un héritage pour tous".
Mon objectif est un peu différent :
c'est de faire de toutes ces propositions
une seule et même proposition.
C'est ce que je nomme
"un revenu d'existence
tout au long de la vie".
Un seul mécanisme,
mais deux modalités de distribution :
De 0 à 18 ans, depuis votre naissance,
une somme serait mise sur un compte public
pour alimenter cette dotation de départ.
Délivré à 18 ans,
mais que vos parents ne toucheraient pas.
Et puis, à partir de 18 ans,
vous pourriez toucher
un revenu d'existence mensuel -
et comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
sans contrepartie, sans condition,
pleinement universel,
pour assurer vos besoins
de fonctionnement quotidiens -
ceux dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure.
Un seul mécanisme, deux modalités,
et puis deux impératifs,
celui que j'ai donné :
la dignité, mais aussi l'émancipation.
Donner à chacun, à chaque enfant,
l'espoir de pouvoir s'émanciper
dans notre société.
Alors, quel est le lien fondamental
qui existe entre notre thème aujourd'hui,
le demos, et le revenu d'existence ?
J'en suis persuadé : le revenu d'existence
est véritablement un projet démocratique,
une véritable alternative pour penser
à un monde meilleur et plus juste.
Pour que Sarah, Mehdi et Valentine
puissent trouver leur parfaite,
exacte et juste place
dans la société dans laquelle nous vivons.
Pour eux comme pour tous nos enfants.
Un projet qui redonne de l'espoir
à l'ensemble de notre société.
(Applaudissements)